from the eu expired on the 30th of june
thank you mr speaker i mean this is this
is basically just another example of the
botched brexit deal failing to take into
the needs um take into account the needs
of a small but very important industry
the industry has now completely
collapsed 30 000 tons of seed haven't
been exported 13.5
million pounds of trade has has is no
longer in place
what is the minister doing to actually
ensure that their an equivalence deal is
reached with the eu
um as soon as possible so that the trade
can be considered um miss you sorry
well uh mr speaker in addition to the
the points i made in uh the answer to my
honourable friend i would point out
point out to the honourable lady that
there is enormous export potential right
around the world particularly in china
and asia further in asia
for scottish seed potato exports this is
something i discussed with industry in
glasgow on monday evening
there is huge potential there and we
will do everything we can to help them
realize that so
question number five mr speaker
uh thank you mr speaker our uk wide
total dwp spend on the labour market
support will increase to more than six
billion pounds this will give everyone a
chance to progress work and develop the
skills they need for the modern
workforce in scotland we have made
available over 15 000 jobs and around 8
000 jobs have already started
so breathless well to fulfill their
potential is key to leveling up
opportunity does my right honourable
friend agree with me that the uk wide
kickstart scheme which has made
available well over 10 000 scottish
placements is yet another example of the
uk government delivering for the people
of scotland
i absolutely agree with my honourable
friend and if i can loot this back to
earlier questions on labour market
issues
i hope that these schemes that this
government is putting forward will help
give the the next generation the skills
uh to fill these domestic vacancies
general secretary of state america
thank you
mr speaker a proper plan for jobs of
course we'd have scottish renewables at
its heart there are four simple steps
the minister could take today to unleash
this proper plan potential firstly
persuade the treasury to create a pot
dedicated to tidal energy in the fourth
contract for difference auctions
secondly instruct offgem to reform
transmission charges to stop
disadvantaging scotland thirdly fund the
energy interconnectors from the island
generators to the mainland and of course
fourthly back the acorn carbon capture
and storage project these government
decisions would not only transform the
uk energy sector but create a scottish
jobs legacy from cop26 so will the
minister demand these cabinet colleagues
act now to create a proper jobs plan for
scotland
well i'm grateful to the honourable
gentleman he does raise the important
issue that
scotland in particular has enormous
potential
in the renewable sector uh particularly
on acorn i can reassure him that project
is not dead it didn't get through to the
first two but as the reserve project and
we will be working closely to make sure
it is in a future one
we are through my department uh we are
funding a number of renewable energy
schemes like core in east asia uh and
you reference tidal in particular in the
islands that can be formed part of the
island's growth deal more generally i'd
be very happy to facilitate a meeting
with my colleagues in bays so we can
discuss the wider issues
thank you mr speaker i would certainly
accept a a meeting with the secretary of
state at base to go over these issues
but i would have thought that the
minister and the scotland office would
also want to champion these because if
one of the outcomes of cop is quite
clear it's we need action and not just
words mr speaker the chancellor's budget
last week didn't have a plan for jobs in
it either in fact he barely mentioned it
the conclusion despite paying more
scottish taxpayers are getting much less
after a
decade of devastating tory and smp
austerity it's no plan for jobs to be
increasing taxes on businesses and
hard-working people at a time when
households and businesses are struggling
with rapidly rising costs so can i ask
the minister is he comfortable and is
his department comfortable as a
conservative minister that under his
government hardworking scots now face
the highest tax burden since the 1950s
thank you mr speaker well firstly on in
the income tax that the scottish
government's responsible it isn't indeed
true that they are have higher taxes
than the rest of the uk and i'll leave
him to take that up with the scottish
government but on the the wider point he
made about uh unemployment and and
employment
if he cast his mind back to the budget
last week the forecast for unemployment
after the pandemic were originally for
about 12 percent it's going to be less
than half that
and through the the changes my right
honourable friend the chancellor are
making
to universal credit tapers for example
that will leave more money in the hands
of hard-working people
thank you mr speaker the turing scheme
has provided funding for more than 40
000 participants from schools colleges
and universities across the uk to study
and work around the globe during this
academic year education providers in
scotland have received more than 8.2
million pounds in funding under the
schemes
uh as one of uh two members of
parliament representing milton keynes in
uh in this piece
i'm particularly proud that the scheme
is named after one of our local heroes
alan turing can my right and more
friends and neighbor confirm to me that
this scheme will be continue to seek
global opportunities for our students
and hope that we can inspire the next
generation of code breakers and
will he join me in welcoming the fact
that there are 28 successful applicants
for scottish projects
and 7.9 million pounds for those
scottish projects this year
thank you mr speaker i i could
absolutely agree with my uh honorable
and close friend uh in milton keynes uh
it is a matter of pride that the scheme
is named after alan turing
and the work that he did to help the
globe i think is entirely fitting that
our global scheme which goes way beyond
the horizons of erasmus uh is proving
such a success and i'm happy to
confirm to him that in my right
honourable friend of chancellor's budget
announcement last week
the funding will be provided to deliver
this scheme for another three years
greg smith
mr speaker i have frequent conversations
with cabinet colleagues about
maintaining and strengthening the
devolution settlement and ensuring that
the government's focus is on delivering
for scotland it is important that all
legislation clearly reflects the
competence and roles of scotland's two
parliaments and two governments
reg smith
thank you mr speaker would my right
honourable friend agree with me that the
key issue here
is for the scottish government to
exercise its existing
powers more effectively rather than
asking for new ones or seeking to go
outside the realms of the scotland act
as my honorable friend will know we
routinely engage with the scottish
government regarding the use of devolved
powers it is in the interest of citizens
across the uk that both governments
operate within their respective powers
as set out in the scotland act 1998 and
that is why mr speaker i flagged to the
deputy first minister back in march that
i felt the uncrc and the eclsg bills
contained sections that were outside the
competent of the scottish government
sadly our warnings and suggestions for
changes to the bills were ignored and so
our law officers referred the relevant
sections of the bills the supreme court
mr speaker the supreme court agreed with
our view on every current i hope that
the scottish government will in future
work with us to ensure that their bills
respect the devolution settlement so
they do not we do not waste any more
time and money but enacting important
legislation
mr speaker
[Applause]
this this government mr speaker is
committed to transitioning the economy
to net zero by 2050 recently published
our net zero strategy which will support
hundreds of thousands of well-paid jobs
and leverage up to 90 billion pounds of
private investment by 2030 across the
entire uk
mccaskill communities must be local as
well as large-scale projects such as
turbine manufacturing that scotland's
sadly missing out on but local
communities such as my own in east lodin
are denied a share of the wealth flowing
ashore
there's a legislative gap to allow
community benefit for onshore as opposed
to offshore offshore as opposed to
onshore wind will the minister meet with
me to discuss this to see if east
lothian and other such communities can
benefit from offshore wind as shetland
has benefited from oil and gas
well i'm always happy to to meet the
honourable gentleman uh but i would
point out to him that this government is
investing heavily in offshore wind
including announcements made this week
by my right honourable friend never know
it
speaker clearly scotland has a lot to
offer not least in its uh high quality
wind uh the net zero um objectives but
can i make my own friend confirmed that
the acorn cc us and hydrogen project is
still very much part of the uk
government's plans uh for uh cc overall
ccos strategy and our objectives to meet
net zero
the short answer is yes as i explained a
moment ago the it wasn't successful to
be in the first two but it is a reserve
uh project and we are actively working
to make sure it is there in future
rounds
final question thank you mr speaker over
97 of scotland's electricity comes from
renewable sources this sector's
expansion is hampered not by potential
but by the highest grid connection
charges in the uk
cop is an opportunity to reassess such
arrangements so what discussions has he
had with cabinet colleagues on reducing
these connection charges
well i regularly meet uh cabinet
colleagues to discuss these matters and
we'll continue to do so
what i would do is point out the
investment my department is making in
renewable energy right across scotland
like the core renewable heat
project in east asher the tidal energy
and offshore wind in shetland we are
making real investment that will make a
real difference to the people's lives
and the planet
right before we come to prime minister's
questions i would like to point out that
the british sign language interpretation
of proceedings is available to watch on
parliament live tv we now come to
preston questions the prime minister
and i start with dr rupert number one
please mr speaker
mr speaker
as the house will be in recess next week
i'm sure the colleagues will join me in
looking ahead to armistice day and
remembering those men and women who have
served and lost their lives in the
service of this country
we also thank the members of our armed
forces who continue to do so today mr
speaker this morning i had meetings with
minister or colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
dr rupa the prime minister has been busy
preaching urgency this week at cop 26 i
hope he caught up with his sleep
but when he sits down with his
grandchildren one day and they ask what
did you do that week of [ __ ] 26 would he
be able to undertake one action in his
gift that would have an immediate impact
would he be consistent with what he's
always said and done and take on the
biggest emitter of co2 in the whole of
europe
that greenery voraciously wants more
willy ditches predecessors damaging daft
free leveling up pre-zoom
free 90 drop in demand and have a fresh
vote in this house to kill off the third
runway at heathrow
mr speaker what this government is going
to do
uh rather than taking uh steps to damage
the economy of of this country what we
are going to do which is what neighbor
would do uh what we are going to do is
get to things get to net zero aviation
uh mr speaker that's the future for this
country clean green aviation and by the
way i think that we have that is has
every chance of arriving a lot earlier
mr speaker than a third runway at
heathrow
james wilde
thank you mr speaker i share my
writeable friends commitment to build
back better to build back greener and to
level up and i have a project that will
deliver on all those things rebuilding
the aging queen elizabeth hospital in
kingsland i've shown him the pictures of
the 200 props holding up its decaying
roof so will the prime minister make the
queen elizabeth one of the eight new
schemes giving people in norfolk
lincolnshire and cambridgeshire the
hospital they need
uh mr speaker i know that my honourable
friend does a huge amount of work for
his constituents i have seen of the
pictures that uh he describes and i can
tell him that uh the application is in
uh from the hospital in his constituency
it is under consideration
and uh we aim to make our final decision
in the spring of next year we now come
to the deputy leader of the labour party
angela rainer
thank you mr speaker ankan share the
opening words from the prime minister
regarding our armed forces and the
tremendous work they do and also send my
best wishes to all those recovering in
salisbury and give our sincere thanks to
the emergency services that responded on
that day and i'd also like to wish all
those celebrating tomorrow a happy and
peaceful diwali
now let me start with something on which
there should be
agreement across all sides of the house
the independent standards process found
that a member broke the ruled rules on
paid lobbying
surely the prime minister accepts that
this is and should be
a serious offence yet we have seen
reports that he will respond by
scrapping the independent process and
overturning its verdict
in no other profession
in our country could someone be found
guilty by an independent process and
just have their mates vote them back
into the job
surely
surely the prime minister and this
government are not going to do that
today
yeah no mr speaker of course we're not
going to do that because a paid lobbying
mr speaker paid advocacy in this house
is wrong and let me make absolutely no
bones about that and members members who
are found guilty of that should
apologize and uh pay the necessary
penalties uh mr speaker but that is not
the issue in this in this case or this
vote that is before us today it is not
the issue
in this case which involved with the
issues in this case which involved a
serious family tragedy mr speaker
is whether a member of this house had a
fair opportunity to make representations
in this case or whether as a ma and
whether as a matter of
natural justice our procedures in this
house allow for proper appeal mr speaker
and that i thought that i think is
something that should be of interest to
members across this house mr speaker and
should be approached properly in a
spirit of moderation and compassion mr
speaker angela rainer
mr speaker
let me put this to him simply
if it was a police officer
a teacher
a doctor we would expect we would expect
the independent protest to be followed
and not changed after the verdict it's
one rule for them and one rule for the
rest of us
mr speaker
when a conservative member was found
guilty of sexual harassment
but let off on a loophole they said the
rules couldn't be changed after the
event
so they can't change the rules to stop
sexual harassment but they can
change the rules to allow cash for
access
so why is the prime minister making it
up as he goes along
mr speaker all the professions that she
mentions have a right of appeal
mr speaker and i
and that is what that is what the house
needs to needs to consider may i
respectfully say to her that i i believe
that she needs to vote instead of
playing politics on on this issue which
is what which is what they which is what
they are doing i think that she needs to
consider the procedures of this house in
a spirit of fairness mr speaker and it
and we on this side lies instead of
playing politics we are getting on with
delivering on the people's priorities mr
speaker 40 more hospitals 20 000 more
police officers and wages that both up
and jobs up across this country those
are our priorities
mr perkins i don't want to say any more
of that either
right
mr speaker this isn't about playing
politics
in this place this is about playing by
the rules
and as we can see it's one rule for
everybody else and one rule for the
conservatives
when they break the rules mr speaker
they just remake the rules
and i know that donald trump is the
prime minister's hero but i say to the
prime minister
i say to the prime minister
in all seriousness he should learn the
lessons that if you keep cheating the
public it catches up with you in the end
[Music]
because while they're wallowing in
sleeves the rest of the country faces
higher bills rising costs and damaging
tax rises so i asked the prime minister
can you tell us what is the projected
tax increase per household over the next
five years yeah
mr speaker what i can tell her is that
the recent budget what the recent budget
did was take cash from those who can
afford uh to pay the most and it had
huge and had very substantial tax cuts
for the hardest working and poorest
families in this country we cut 1 000
pounds mr speaker with the universal
credit taper relief cut for the for hard
working families in this country 2
million families had a 1 000 packet and
we're lifting the living wage across the
whole country mr speaker and what we are
also doing mr speaker is ensuring that
this country gets on with a high wage
high skill jobs-led recovery and never
let it be forgotten that if we listen to
them we would have none of those things
mr speaker because we'd still be in
lockdown
lorena
mr speaker i think he missed out the
number so let me help him out
the resolution foundation found that by
2026 taxes will be 3 000 pounds more per
household since he took office
my constituents and his constituents are
feeling the pinch and they're worried
about christmas as well mr speaker their
bills are going up every week and the
budget did nothing to help them so can
the prime minister tell them
how much was the tax cut that he gave to
the banks instead
mr speaker
as she knows very well it is the it is
the banks and the bankers who are paying
far more proportionately as a result of
our tax measures to cover the cost of
the nhs and actually it's a very moot
point because the 36 billion pounds uh
which came from 50 of it comes from the
the 14 of the 14 percent who are the
richest in this country mr speaker
overwhelmingly from the banks and
financial services industry who can pay
the most and the astonishing thing mr
speaker is when it came when it came to
when it came to voting for that 36
billion pound increase in 48 new
hospitals in 50 000 more nurses in
looking after our public services they
voted against it mr speaker
angela rainer
mr speaker according to the prime
minister's own budget documents it was 4
billion pounds in tax cuts to the
bankers and 3 000 pounds of tax risers
per household good news for the donors
who gave his party half a million pounds
his bank got a bonus of nearly eight
million pounds but not the good news for
the rest of us mr speaker
now mr speaker
this month as the prime minister said we
remember and celebrate all those who
serve our great country and all those
who have lost their lives leaving behind
loved ones and those who have sustained
life-changing injuries and live every
day with the consequences of their
sacrifice
yet hidden in the small print of the
budget
was a billion pound cut to day-to-day
defense spending
so mr speaker
will our service men and women face pay
cuts
or will there be fewer of them with less
support yeah
mr speaker i think it's quite incredible
that we're now hearing this from the
from the labour party uh when uh they
would have pulled us out of out of nato
and and uh and actually and i think the
the right normal lady actually wanted to
abolish the army what do you what do you
brought so what did you publish the army
the woman sitting next to her mr speaker
what what you've got in this government
is spending on on defense which is the
highest since the cold war the biggest
uplift since the cold war and
an increase that has restored confidence
in this country around the world in our
ability to defend not just our own
shores but to defend our friends and
partners as well and that is what this
government is doing
[Applause]
mr speaker he knows that i asked him
about the annual defense budget which
his own budget document show will drop
by 1.3 billion pounds and i hear the
prime minister's fine words i'm from a
military family myself but i won't take
party political lectures from him
because too often the government's
actions don't match their words
and mr speaker i think of my constituent
who fought in afghanistan and yet was
threatened with sanctions because he was
unable to physically travel miles to the
nearest dwp office
the prime minister's tax cut for
short-haul flights last week cost 30
million pounds that is 50
more than the government spends on
supporting veterans mental health each
year
the charity
combat stress has lost 6 million pounds
in funding this year even as they're
called to their helpline of doubled
so will the prime minister match our
proposal to reinfest the 35 million
saved from cancelled mod contracts to
support
our veterans that surely deserve it
mr speaker it's because we've been able
to run a strong economy and take our
economy out of lockdown but we've been
able to invest massively in the nhs
we've been able to lift spending on
defense to record levels and to keep
supporting our fantastic public services
that is what this government is able to
do mr speaker and i i must say i enjoy
my conversations with her in spite of
the insults that she uh the party
political policy uh she directs it uh
towards us mr speaker i may say without
i don't want to cause any further
dissension in the benches in the bench
is opposite but i think you will agree
she has about a gigawatt more energy mr
speaker than the right honourable
gentleman her friend
and son
i'm just putting it out there but it's
but it's the same it's the same
old labor no plan no ideas we're getting
on mr speaker we're delivering on the
people's priorities we're taking this
country forward growth up jobs up wages
up productivity up all they do mr
speaker is play politics while we
deliver
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker and can i thank the
prime minister and the government for
securing our fantastic so-called trend
leveling up funding
to truly level up opportunities and
access to opportunities in
stoke-on-trent we must also improve our
poor public transport so would my
rational friend agree to look at the
possibility for bus franchising in the
potteries
i i i as my older friend knows i'm a
fanatic about buses i will i will i will
urge urge him uh uh i would to take up
his we're putting 1.2 billion more into
into bus funding and i know that
stoke-on-trent has applied but can i
suggest that he takes his his suggestion
up uh immediately with uh with uh uh my
normal friend the secretary of state for
transport you come to smp's first person
in blackford
thank you
mr speaker and can i also as we look
forward to remembering somebody commend
those that that served and the
the military services that protect all
of us the security services for the job
that they continue to do
mr speaker
so david attenborough's powerful opening
statement to cop 26
told us that the journey to net zero
means we must recapture
billions of tons of carbon from the air
the committee on climate change has been
clear that carbon capture and storage is
a necessity not an option to achieve the
planet's net zero targets this week
scotland's world leading climate targets
have received widespread praise from
amongst others the un secretary general
scotland is finding partners across the
world to tackle the climate emergency
but in westminster there isn't even a
willing partner to deliver the carbon
capture project that was long promised
scotland's northeast
has now been waiting weeks for a clear
reason to exactly why the scottish
cluster bid was rejected there have been
no clear answers not even clear excuses
so maybe the prime minister will answer
the simple question does he know exactly
how much of the uk's co2 storage the
scottish cluster could deliver
mr speaker i'm a massive enthusiast for
carbon capture and storage around the
whole of the uk the acorn project in
aberdeen remains as he knows on the on
the reserve list he should not give up
we will we will come back to this and of
course we want to make sure that we have
a fantastic uh fantastic industry
generating a clean hydrogen around the
country he should he should not despair
in the meantime uh we are supporting
amazing scottish plans uh to get a clean
energy uh from wind from uh from
hydrogen from all sorts of means mr
speaker and i may say i want to thank
the people of scotland and i thank the
people of glasgow for the way they they
helped to produce so far what i think
has been a fantastically well organized
summit in blackfoot
mr speaker it's bad enough that the
prime minister rejected the scottish
cluster a week before top but what's
worse
he clearly doesn't even know or
understand what his government was
rejecting
so let me tell him the scottish cluster
bid would have stored 30 percent
of the uk co2 emissions and it would
have supported the creation of around 20
000 jobs in green industries it was by
far and away the best bid prime minister
if this decision was based on science
alone it would have been approved on
this spot it is obvious that this was a
political decision in westminster to
reject it
with days left at the cop summit will
the prime minister now reverse his
government's massive own goal when it
rejected the scottish cluster
mr pico i'm trying to encourage the
right honourable gentleman to be a
little bit less gloomy
about the about the prospects of
of this initiative we i i understand
exactly what he says and what we're
doing is working with the scottish
government and i i thank the scottish
government for their cooperation all the
support they gave to cop as well in the
last few days and weeks and what they're
doing what they're doing we will come
back to this uh mr speaker but let us
but let us like what i mean what i may
say is that i think uh if what i think
is is working well is the spirit of
cooperation uh between uh between all
levels of government in this country and
what doesn't work is confrontation
thank you mr speaker house prices are
rising in east devon with the dream of
home ownership becoming out of reach for
too many local people
new build developments must be
affordable with protections in place to
restrict number of properties becoming
second homes the loophole which allows
second homeowners to avoid paying
council tax should be closed quickly to
help local authorities will the prime
minister meet with me and colleagues
from across the southwest to discuss
this growing crisis across our region
yeah uh mr speaker i know how strongly
my honourable friend and other
colleagues across the southwest feel
about this this issue and that's why
we've legislated to introduce higher
rates of stamp duty on second homes and
we will ensure that only genuine holiday
businesses can access small business
rate relief mr speaker uh but i'm happy
certainly to to meet with colleagues to
discuss what further we may do to ensure
that local people get the homes they
need bill andre
speaker scotland is vital for the uk's
energy needs both currently and in the
future it's also vital for future
offshore capabilities and other low
carbon and renewable energies not my
words but those of the minister for
energy confirming that it is the rest of
the uk that is dependent on scotland not
the other way around does the prime
minister not realize that his failure to
invest in carbon capture and storages in
ferguson grangemouth and feeding the
potential it must mourn in my
constituency is regarded as an act of
deliberate economic vandalism casting
himself less is bond and more has
blowfield the villain
for all of the cop 26 world to see
mr speaker what the cop 26 world can see
is the astonishing achievements of
scotland and the rest of the uk
in developing clean energy sources and
i've said to the to the right honourable
gentleman that the leader of his party
in in westminster though we will come
back to to the aberdeen uh the aberdeen
uh sorry forgive me he's a member of a
different party forgive me uh uh
so essentially the same agenda uh though
mr speaker uh we will come back to this
and uh what and what i i found
encouraging about the last few days is
the spirit of cooperation and joint
enterprise that i now detect that will
enable us to deliver massive carbon cuts
across this whole country peter gibbs
thank you mr speaker darlington station
is receiving 105 million pounds thanks
to this government
plans to make it hs2 ready
i want to make sure that darlington
benefits from high-speed rail so will my
right honourable friend meet with myself
and regional colleagues to discuss the
eastern leg of hs2 and reopening the
lean sideline to allow the whole region
to be better connected
uh well my honorable friend i thank my
and i i i thank you for everything he's
doing for darlington uh and i he should
wait for the the integrated rail plan to
come out but in the meantime
we are upgrading uh darlington station
there are plans in place and my uh right
on friend the chancellor announced 310
million pounds of funding over the next
five years to transform local transport
networks in the tees valley
okay
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
says he's a fanatic on of buses but what
about trains and not just in darlington
but at the mention of the limb side uh
liam sideline because last wednesday i
was notified that a joint bid to
reinstate the mothball gleam sideline
had not been successful in attracting
the next stage of the feasibility
funding from the government as part of
the restoring your your railway fund so
can i ask the prime minister what
specific plans does the government have
to invest in the north east in places
like gateshead and south tyneside in my
constituency and when is he going to get
serious about leveling up in our
communities instead of just using the
term as a meaningless populist slogan
well mr speaker again she must wait for
the integrated royal plan but then the
northeast uh will be the beneficiary of
the biggest the biggest investment in
our our rail infrastructure beyond hs2
uh that we've seen for a century about
96 billion pounds more that we are going
to be putting in and uh and what we want
is we we want the local authorities we
want the regional authorities to work
with us to ensure that we promote the
projects that the people really want i'm
drilled
thank you mr speaker
thank you again i want to really thank
my right honourable friend for his
support for the early years healthy
development review
and in particular for the half a billion
of new money at spending review last
week my right honourable friend often
says that talent is spread equally
across our country but opportunity is
not so does he agree with me that giving
every baby the best start for life is
the best possible way to level up across
our country
yes i i thank because i've listened to
my right honourable friend over many
years
on this issue and she is 100
right in what she says by what she says
about the importance of early years and
that's why we're investing 500 million
pounds to support families and children
including 82 million pounds to create a
network of family hubs to bring together
services for children of all ages and
we're going to continue mr speaker to
invest in children's early years for
example for 15 hours of early education
for disadvantaged two-year-olds that's
already benefited 1.1 million
disadvantaged kids since 2013.
[Music]
thank you mr speaker i was recently
contacted by a vauxhall constituent
whose mother tragically committed
suicide after criminal domestic abuse by
her husband with the inquest into her
suicide finding his actions to be direct
calls
incredibly her abuser now stand to
inherit her pension and entire state
because she was unable to complete
divorce this has left the family
devastated and i'm sure the whole house
will join me in sending them our
condolences
does the prime minister agree with me
that convicted domestic abusers should
never be able to profit from the crimes
of their victims and will he meet with
my constituent and me to fix this hole
in the law yeah
uh mr speaker she describes a truly
tragic and and appalling case and i'm
sure the whole house will share the uh
revulsion that that she's expressed at
the uh the outcome of the of the laws
processes i think we will certainly uh
need to have a meeting in order to see
what we can do to address uh this
loophole
nhs staff perform magnificently in the
pandemic but there are now severe
shortages in nearly every specialty so
will my right honourable friend support
an amendment to the health bill backed
by 50 nhs organizations every royal
college to require health education
england to do regular independent
forecasts of the numbers of doctors and
nurses that we should be training so
that we can reassure people despite the
pressure today we are at least training
enough doctors and nurses for the future
speaker my my right normal friend is
absolutely right that we've got to make
sure our nhs has the the staff that it
that it needs and that's why there are
50 000 more
more health care professionals in the
nhs this year than there were last year
uh 12 000 more nurses mr speaker and and
in addition there are 60 000 nurses at
60 000 nurses in training uh mr speaker
some uh as somebody asked opposite why
are there waiting this where can we be
through a pandemic mr speaker
and and what we're doing is fixing those
waiting lists fixing those weightiness
with 36 billion pounds of investment
which that party opposite voted against
mr speaker
thank you mr speaker it's a little over
a year since i last challenged the prime
minister over his campaign promises to
the 1950s born woman
in which time he has done he ha about
their pension and justices so can you
tell me today does his government have
any plans to deliver justice for the
women involved
[Music]
mr speaker this is a very difficult
issue there's a whole house knows in the
in the case of the wasp women is is not
easily uh addressed uh as
as right as the honourable gentleman
knows the the expenditure involved is
very considerable the tax that would
have to be raised uh would be very
considerable but we continue to reflect
on all the options uh to ensure they
ensure that people across this country
get fair pensions
jill bolton
thank you mr speaker
as a mother i cannot begin to imagine
the pain and torment of losing a child
richard lee a constituent of mine and
veteran who served a distinction in the
british army has been living with this
pain every day of his life since the
28th of november 1981.
on that day his daughter katrice lee
went missing from a military shopping
complex near paderborn in germany it was
katrice's second birthday
and her family are still searching
the 40th anniversary of catrice's
disappearance is coming up at the end of
this month which will undoubtedly be an
exceptionally painful event for the
entire lee family
would the prime minister please agree to
meet with mr lee father to father and
reassure him that catrice has not been
forgotten
yes i thank my honourable friend for
raising this absolutely tragic case and
i know that the thoughts of the whole
house will be uh with catrice lee's
family and uh of course uh mr speaker i
will agree to my honorable friends a
request and meet mr lee father the
father
so agree
the epilepsy society is a charity and
world leading research centre based in
my constituency they started the
epilepsy climate change initiative to
better understand the effects of global
warming on epilepsy and the impact is
already clear
a recent survey showed that in hot
weather 62 of those whose seizures were
uncontrolled experienced an increase in
seizure frequency or severity will the
prime minister join me in endorsing the
epilepsy climate change initiative and
commit to more funding to research the
impact of climate change on human health
i thank the honorable lady for her
question she raises a very interesting
uh aspect of research into epilepsy
we're funding uh epilepsy research with
with uh another 54 million pounds uh
over the last few years and uh this
issue that she raises of any partic
particular link uh between hot weather
or climate change and epilepsy is
certainly one uh that we will be going
into
elite colburn
speaker last week an independent inquiry
into lib dem run sutton council's own
heat network found that it was set up on
false assumptions inc
including funding that was never
attained and poems that do not exist and
now my constituents are going to be left
footing the bill does the prime minister
agree with me that this latest failure
shows that they are just not fit to
govern and that those responsible should
go
yeah well mr speaker not the first time
that uh the lib dems have campaigned on
homes that don't exist or never exist uh
if i remember if i think of their
campaign in cheshire
uh mr speaker uh but i will certainly
look into the matter that he raises
mr speaker in a recent itv interview the
prime minister
was asked about my constituent jenny
garrett now jenny is a victim of the
cladding scandal just before last
christmas her building was evacuated
because of safety concerns she's been
forced to pay five and a half thousand
pounds for a waking watching alarms she
has to find 1200 a year for car parking
she can no longer access the work needed
to make her building safe is being
blocked by the actions of her freeholder
she doesn't know the cost she'll face
but it's estimated at thousands of
pounds
yet in his interview the prime minister
said jenny had
quote
a frankly unnecessary sense of anxiety
so will he meet her to hear why she's
worried and do so do so before the
building safety bill completes its
passage through the house
i'm afraid to say the the honourable
gentleman i have every sympathy with his
constituent mr speaker and and uh
and i and i certainly do that well mr
speaker i i have every sympathy
i have every sympathy but what i think
is unfair is that people uh such as her
are placed in a position of unnecessary
anxiety about their homes when they
should be when they should be reassured
and i think it is i sympathize deeply uh
with people who have to pay for for
waking watches and other such things i
think it i think it is absurd i think it
is absurd mr speaker but i think what
what people should be doing is making
sure is making sure that we do not
unnecessarily
undermine the confidence of the market
and the people of
in in these homes because they are
fundamental they are not unsafe many
many millions of homes are not unsafe
and he should have the courage mr
speaker to say so i would
thank you mr speaker
the new police and crime commissioner
for the west midlands has chosen to cut
back
on stop and search in the west across
the region
can the prime minister confirm that
while stop and searches
must be proportionate and not
discriminatory they remain an important
part of keeping our streets and our
communities
yes mr speaker i certainly agree uh with
that and it was a point that i raised
recently with the labour mayor of london
we agreed on
many things uh we we
he was very much out of line with the
current labor policy on uh on lockdown
for instance uh but he did certainly i
certainly i certainly thought that he
was wrong about about stop and search
and we need to make sure that stop and
search is part of the uh the armory of
uh police options when it comes to
stopping knife crime if it's done
sensitively and in accordance with the
law i believe it can be extremely
valuable
thank you mr speaker
prime minister we can save the uk
taxpayer 200 million pounds and level up
south london's health service
helio hospital is set to lose its a e
maternity intensive care children
service renal unit and 62
of beds
to healthy wealthy belmont at a
staggering cost of 600 million but there
is an alternative
rebuild helia where health is poorest
and save 200 million
now it's not my job to help the prime
minister sort out his budget but
wouldn't this be a good place to start
mr speaker we are we are investing in 48
uh hospital new hospitals and and
rebuilds and what is her job what is her
job quite frankly is to vote for 36
billion pounds of investment in the nhs
which which will allow us to take our
health services forward why wouldn't you
do that mr speaker
robert
thank you mr speaker can i commend the
prime minister on his diplomatic efforts
in recent weeks and ask him about
another serious and grave issue that was
raised at the g20 in rome the strong
likelihood of a nuclear-ready iran
within a matter of weeks
what is the uk going to do with our
international partners to tackle that if
it is via an agreement will it be
stronger and more enduring than the last
one and if it's not as many people
suspect what is our plan b yeah
mr speaker i think it's in the interest
overwhelming interests of the and this
is what we i thank you very much for his
question he is an issue he knows a great
deal about this is this is a case of
making it clear to the iranians that
there is an opportunity for them to do
something that i think be massively in
the interests of their people and of
iran which is to come back to the table
and do a a further agreement the son of
of jcpo restore the jcpoa at the vienna
talks that is what needs to happen that
is the posture of the uh of the g20 and
indeed of of our friends and allies
around the world okay vicky fox rock
[Music]
thank you mr speaker the universal
credit card is already hitting people
hard
even before the challenges of the
pandemic 39 of children in my
constituency grew up in poverty now
depth of first a local charity eye chair
has launched a fundraising campaign to
support people through the winter months
the prime minister is well known for his
abilities to attract wealthy donors to
the party
um will he use those skills to boost our
campaign or even better will he cancel
the cut
mr speaker what we've done with
universal credit is abolish uh abolish
the the old system that unfairly taxed
people on universal credit and and
helped people uh with a one million
pound tax cut because what we on this
side of the house believe in is
rewarding work mr speaker that's what
the people of this country want to see
that's why we've put the tax cut on on
those who are on universal that's why
we're lifting the living wage mr speaker
and never what's their policy on
universal credit no no it's not it's not
nothing they want to abolish universal
credit mr speaker
thank you mr speaker the mayor of london
is refusing to rule out the so-called
outer london charge
which would apply to all vehicles
registered outside greater london across
the greater london boundary
now this would have terrible
consequences for my opinion constituents
and indeed those people who live in the
neighboring constituency of old bexley
and syd cup now louie french the
excellent local candidate for the
by-election
has pledged to fight this appalling
proposal
would my right noble friend join me in
wishing louis french luck with this and
to ensure that this silly move from the
mayor of london is stopped in its tracks
[Applause]
i certainly do uh agree i agree with my
honorable friend who who is an old
friend of mine worked closely with him
on london issues for many years and uh i
know where i know where labour's
instincts are they always want to put
taxes up particularly uh particularly on
on motorists and i think i think
i think a checkpoint tig
would hit working families mr speaker
and what the labour mayor of london
needs to do is get a grip on on tfl's
finances and stop whacking up the taxes
on ordinary people in us in the capital
city that's in docker to use i'm very
grateful mr speaker
the prime minister is very much aware of
my constituent jagdtar singh johal
abducted by plainclothes officers while
shopping with his new wife in the city
of jolanda punjab on the 4th of november
the intervening years mr speaker has
seen allegations of torture overlooked
and ostensibly strong words from his
government about the case
overshadowed by excitement over a trade
deal with the republic of india
therefore mr speaker as we approach the
fourth anniversary of jagtar's arrest
tomorrow
with no charges having been brought in
the case by the government of india
would his government be able to grant
the smallest of favors to jagtar's wife
and his family in dumbarton and declare
his detention an arbitrary one
mr speaker i
thank him for the campaign that he's
been running for jack tasting for a long
time and what i would say to him is that
uh our the closeness of our relationship
with india in no way diminishes our
willingness to raise that case with the
government of india indeed my right
honourable friend the foreign secretary
raised it only uh the last time she was
in india
final question ruth
unlike the party opposite i welcome the
record investment in the nhs
now will my right honorable friend
support my campaign for a new health
center in rushcliff in the village of
eastleak where the current building is
no longer big enough to serve the
current population and they will soon
need to accommodate 3 000 new patients
from new building
[Applause]
i'm sure my right on the health
secretary will do his utmost uh in the
course of the the coming decisions to
oblige uh my friend in her campaign a
justified campaign uh for rushcliff and
its hustle but mr speaker how incredible
uh that the labour party should continue
to catcall
and attack the government when they
voted against the tax rising measures
that are necessary that are necessary to
fund our nhs they are completely
inconsistent mr speaker they have
absolutely no plans and no idea
[Music]
we now come to the statement
we don't come to the prime minister
prime minister johnson
thank you thanks
mr speaker with your permission i'll
make a statement about the g20 summit in
rome and update the house on cop 26 in
glasgow
almost 30 years ago
the world acknowledged the gathering
danger of climate change and agreed to
do what would have once been
inconceivable
and regulate the atmosphere of the
planet itself by curbing greenhouse gas
emissions
and one declaration succeeded another
until
in paris in 2015
we all agreed to seek to restrain the
rise in world temperatures to 1.5
degrees centigrade
now
after all the targets and the promises
and after yet more warnings from our
scientists about the peril staring at us
in the face
we come
to the reckoning
this is the moment when we must turn
words into action if we fail then paris
will have failed and every summit going
back to rio de janeiro in 1992 will have
failed
because we will have allowed our shared
aim of 1.5 degrees to escape our grasp
even
half a degree of extra warming would
have tragic consequences
if global temperatures were to rise by 2
degrees
our scientists forecast that we will
lose virtually all of the world's coral
reefs
the great barrier reef and countless
other living marvels would dissolve into
an ever warmer and ever more acidic
ocean
returning the terrible verdict that
human beings lacked the will to preserve
the wonders of the natural world and in
the end mr speaker it is a question of
will
we have the technology to do what is
necessary
all that remains in question is our
resolve
the g20 summit convened by our italian
friends and cop 26 partner last weekend
provided encouraging evidence that the
political will exists
which is vital for the simple reason
that the g20 accounts for 80
of the world economy and 75
of greenhouse gas emissions
britain
was the first g20 nation to promise in
law to wipe out our contribution to
climate change by achieving net zero
and as recently as 2019 only one other
member had made a comparable pledge
today
18 countries in the g20 have made
specific commitments to achieve net zero
and in the rome declaration last sunday
everyone every member acknowledged and i
quote the key relevance achieving of
achieving global net zero greenhouse gas
emissions or carbon neutrality by or
around mid-century
to that end the g20 including china
including china agreed to stop financing
new international unabated coal projects
by the end of this year a vital step
towards consigning coal to history
and every member repeated their
commitment to the paris target of 1.5
degrees in a spirit of cooperation
the summit reached other important
agreements
the g20 will levy a minimum corporation
tax rate of 15 percent
ensuring that multinational companies
make a fair contribution wherever they
operate
over 130 countries and jurisdictions
have now joined this arrangement showing
what we can achieve together when the
will exists
the g20 adopted a target of vaccinating
70 percent of the world's population
against covid by the middle of next year
and the uk is on track to provide 100
million doses to this effort
by the end of this year we will have
donated over 30 million doses of the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine and at least
another 20 million will follow next year
along with 20 million doses of the
jansen vaccine ordered by the government
and the g20
resolved
to work together
to ease supply chain disruptions which
have affected every member as demand
recovers and the world economy gets back
on its feet
i pay tribute to prime minister mario
draghi for his expert handling of the
summit
but everyone will accept that far more
needs to be done
to spare humanity from catastrophic
climate change
and in the meantime
global warming
is already contributing to droughts and
brush fires and hurricanes summoning an
awful vision of what lies ahead if we
fail to act in the time that remains
so
the biggest summit
that the united kingdom has ever hosted
is now underway in glasgow
bringing together 120 world leaders with
the aim of translating aspirations into
action to keep the ambition of 1.5
degrees alive
i'm grateful to glasgow city council to
police scotland uh to the police across
the whole of the uk
and to our public health bodies
for making this occasion possible and
all their hard work
for millions of people across the world
the outcome
is literally a matter of life or death
for some island states in the pacific
and caribbean
it is a question of national survival
the negotiations in glasgow have almost
two weeks to run
but we can take heart from what has been
achieved so far
nations which together comprise 90
percent of the world economy
are now committed to net zero up from 30
percent when the uk took over the reigns
of cop
yesterday alone
the united states and over a hundred
other countries agreed to cut their
emissions of methane one of the most
destructive greenhouse gases by 30
by 2030
and
122 countries with over 85 percent of
the world's forests agreed to end and
reverse deforestation by the same
deadline backed by the greatest ever
commitment of public funds to this cause
which i hope will trigger even more from
the private sector
india has agreed to transform her energy
system to derive half her power from
renewable sources keeping a billion tons
of carbon out of the atmosphere
the uk has doubled our commitment to
international climate finance to 11.6
billion and we will contribute another 1
billion pounds if the economy grows as
is forecast we've launched our clean
green initiative which will help the
developing world to build new
infrastructure in an environmentally
friendly way and we will invest three
billion pounds of public money to unlock
billions more from the private sector
i've asked the world the uk has asked
the world for action on coal cars
cash
and trees
and we have begun to make progress
substantial palpable progress on three
out of the four
but the negotiations in glasgow have a
long way to go mr speaker and far more
must be done
whether we can summon the collective
wisdom and will to save ourselves from
an avoidable
disaster
still hangs in the balance
and we will press on with the hard work
until the last hour mr speaker i commend
this statement
i call the deputy leader of the party to
respond
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
the prime minister for advanced site of
the statement and for updating the house
on the g20 summit in rome
it cannot be overstated how crucial the
next week and a half is
i am pleased to see that there has been
some progress as the prime minister
outlined but the next 10 days needs to
be
needs to move beyond pre-packed
announcements this is an opportunity for
britain mr speaker alongside our friends
and allies around the world to deliver
historic change by taking action
to reduce emissions right now
in this decade
we can avoid the worst effects of
climate change
this cannot just be a political ambition
it is necessity for humanity
so mr speaker as the g20 ends and cop 26
continues
i want to assure the prime minister
everybody on these benches is desperate
for cop26 to be a success
we hope that our negotiations can bring
people together and deliver the urgent
solutions to the biggest challenge
our world has ever faced
however mr speaker there is some cause
for concern
the g20 needed to be a springboard to
their cop26 a real opportunity to show
britain's diplomatic strength in
bringing people together but also in
applying pressure where it's needed
to convince
the big polluters to meet the
commitments to 1.5 degrees and to find
solutions to phase out fossil fuels
and to ensure a just transition for
workers and to create a fairer and
greener economy
but mr speaker the g20 did not achieve
this
the prime minister is failing in his
efforts to convince the world leaders
that more must be done
he has welcomed the commitments in the
distant future and i accept that
when he knows all too well
that we need to have the carbon
emissions now at least by the end of
this decade if we are to keep global
temperatures down
it is a time
for urgent climate action now
not more climate delay
now mr speaker we all know how difficult
it is to convince the world
to curtail carbon emissions
but it is our responsibility to do so
it is the prime minister's
responsibility to influence world
leaders and lead by example
but as we try to convince other
countries to phase out coal this
government is refusing to make its mind
up about coal mines within its own
borders
they could have followed the lead of the
welsh labor government and changed
planning policy to make sure that no new
coal mines had been developed but they
didn't
and as we tried to convince big emitters
to do more when it comes to reducing
emissions
unfortunately this government are
agreeing a trail trade deal with
australia that removes key climate
pledges that's right it's undermining
our messages by giving a free pass to
our friends and mr speaker
when britain must convince the
wealthiest nations in the world to
pledge more money to help developing
countries cut their emissions and adapt
to climate change
what's this government done
they cut development aid that would have
funded vital climate projects how does
the prime minister
expect to convince others to do more
when he is setting such a poor example
mr speaker
mr speaker
i also want to raise the issue of global
the
vaccinations
last week agreed a vague promise to
explore ways to accelerate global
vaccination against covert 19.
yet in some of the world's poorest
countries less than 3 percent of people
have received even one dose of the
vaccine
and we all know we live in a globalized
world where more of the virus that
spreads the greater the threat of new
variants
we are not safe here from colvid until
people are safe from colvid everywhere
and there's no more time for rhetoric
it's time for action and the prime
minister mentioned our efforts on
vaccines but it was revealed last week
that the uk is lagging behind all of the
g7 countries bar one
in sharing surplus vaccines with poor
countries this mr speaker is shameful
our fantastic scientists that developed
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine are being
let down by our prime minister's actions
we need booster jobs in manchester and
vaccines shared with madagascar it's now
time for actions prime minister not
words so as the world
as the world gathers over the next two
weeks we all hope for a breakthrough
that we need
now britain has a proud history of
building alliances and standing up for
what's right and i've no doubt that
we'll be able to do it again
and i do wish
the prime minister well in his efforts
and i ask him
to pay attention and go for the detail
on this because if he fails
because if he fails to deliver mr
speaker if he fails to deliver the
change that we need through this
conference we will all pay the price
well mr speaker the the right normal
lady asked me to go for the detail
having said some rather some kind things
about her approach just now i think
after listening to that i i prefer the
forensic approach of the pseudo-forensic
approach of the of the member for hobart
so patrick she's completely she's
completely in ignorance of the basic
facts mr speaker uh we've cut we've cut
our co2 emissions by 44 on 1990 levels
very largely by moving uh from eighty
percent dependence on coal uh 50 years
ago to about one or two percent today it
is a massive cut uh we haven't cut our
uh our investment in overseas
development date for climate change
funding no we have not mr speaker we've
known it we've kept it 11 at 11.6
billion and then i don't know whether
she was paying attention to the news mr
speaker but only the other day we
announced another billion pounds mr
speaker which were able which were able
to do which were able to do because of
the growth in the economy and as as for
what she's she's she's completely wrong
about the facts as for as for what she
said about uh vaccines i'm afraid it is
an insult to the incredible work that's
been done by
the uk vaccine rollout program across
the world what 1.5 billion people mr
speaker have had access to cost price
vaccines
thanks to the deal that this government
did with oxford astrazeneca a record
that no other country in the world in
the world has to say nothing of the 548
million pounds extra uh that we put into
into gabby or the extra 100 million uh
vaccines that were donating by june next
year this country has an absolutely
outstanding record in supporting
vaccination around the world and if she
wants to go and look at the detail that
i i urge her to go off and uh and study
it i i think she but i i welcome mr
speaker the broad thrust of what she was
saying about about cop 26 because i
think what she was saying there was that
she sees signs of of progress but a lot
more to do which is i think and i think
frankly there she is there she is right
uh if i could just point to the things
that happened since uh g20 i i would i
would draw her attention to india's
massive commitment to cut uh co2 by by
2030 that by cleaning up uh their power
system i point to the 10 billion pounds
uh from japan i'd have 10 billion
dollars from japan over the next five
years uh to support developing countries
around the world and i think i would
also point to
not just brazil but russia and china and
110 countries around the world signing
up to the forestry uh declaration to
halt de holton reverse uh deforestation
by 2030. i think that's a very
considerable achievement
and it will make a huge difference and
we will use consumer power and the power
of corporations and the private sector
private sector around the world to
affect that change and the the single
most important thing for me that came
out of of cop was an agreement around
the world about the basic intellectual
approach now being taken by the uk
through the clean green initiative and
what uh joe biden calls the build that
better world initiative and that is the
the thing that offers the greatest hope
for humanity because we're we're not
just putting in government money to help
countries around the world clean up uh
and putting in development date money
though we are uh we're massively
supporting that we're now leveraging in
the trillions the tens perhaps hundreds
of trillions of private sector
investment and that is the way to make
the difference and that is if we can get
that right at this cop it will be a
truly remarkable thing but as i say
there is still a long way to go sir
edward lee yeah yeah
given that we are now taxing people at a
higher rate than any time since
we were impoverished on the government
and given that despite the fact we only
produced one percent of global emissions
and china produces 27
and we are now loading further controls
on our industry which they are not
matching in china in india further
eroding our competitive advantage will
the prime minister grip all his spending
departments and ensure that we root out
wasted incompetence and create a genuine
enterprise low tax economy prime
minister
yes mr speaker and that's why we still
have among the lowest corporation taxes
uh in the oecd in spite of the measures
that we've been obliged to take because
of the pandemic and that's why we put in
just a for instance the the 125
super deduction for companies to invest
in capital invest in infrastructure and
expand their their businesses and the
results the benefits are already being
seen just in uh in gigabit broadband
alone mr speaker
we know country and blackford the leader
of the assembly thank you mr speaker and
can i thank the prime minister for
advanced site of his statement mr
speaker
g20 was an opportunity to build momentum
ahead of the
cop summit but i think
even the prime minister would admit
that the summit largely failed to meet
the demand and desire for people for
increased global cooperation
if we are to meet the global challenges
that all of humanity now faces
that needs to change
and change very quickly with a
meaningful agreement in glasgow over the
course of the coming week and all of us
hope that that indeed will be the case
on climate change
we know that the g20 are responsible for
80
of global greenhouse gas emissions so it
is right
that it's the g1020 members that bear
the biggest responsibility
countries that have contributed the
least to this climate crisis
must not be left to pay the biggest
price and that's why mr speaker there
has to be a commitment to climate
justice and why this is so important
in scotland we've recently doubled our
climate justice fund to 6 million pounds
per year providing
24 million pounds
over the scottish parliament session but
the commitments from the largest nations
in the g20 always seemed to be heavily
caviated
on monday the prime minister promised 1
billion in uk aid for climate finance
but here's the catch
only if the uk economy grows as forecast
it's exactly the same excuse
that is presented when it comes to the
government's disgraceful policy of cuts
to overseas aid
so
can i ask the prime minister
when will the uk government stop
caveating its commitment to climate
justice and follow scotland's leadership
and establish a climate justice fund
on afghanistan
can i ask what country actions and
timelines were agreed to help end the
terrible famine that is ripping through
that country and finally on covet
what specific targets and timelines were
agreed to rapidly increase vaccine
rollout to those nations that are being
left behind in the suppression of the
virus
prime minister mr speaker first of all
on
the
climate finance for the for the world
he's making a valid point because it's
absolutely essential that the developed
world supports uh the developing world
on the path to decarbonization but that
is and that's why the hundred billion uh
dollars is uh per year is so important
and uh contributions such as the
japanese that we saw uh yesterday uh
what the french have done what the
germans have done uh what joe biden uh
did the other day these are these are
important steps but there is much more
to be done but being a doubt uh he
should be very proud of what the uk is
committing 11.6 billion uh that we said
two years ago plus another billion uh
the day before yesterday these are big
sums now uh that the uk is uh is is
giving we are way out uh in front on the
uh
his point about uh afghanistan and he's
right to raise it uh we we had uh
sad but good discussions about
afghanistan and were determined to work
together to concert our humanitarian
lead to relief to do uh what we can and
not withstanding uh the difficulties
that they're obviously are going to be
with our relations with the the taliban
and on the on the global vaccine roll
out
the he'll have heard the commitments
made by uh countries around the world
and i think the uk can be very proud of
what we're doing uh on top of uh the 1.5
billion
astrazeneca another 100 million doses by
june next year
so desmond sway to what extent does the
success of the entire enterprise
depend upon the promised finance to the
developing world
prime minister
very largely
i'd like to thank the prime minister for
all his efforts to try to make cop 26 a
success
for many of us halting climate change
has been the passion of our lives can i
ask the prime minister to confirm
reports i've heard
that the british negotiating team in
glasgow
is seriously concerned
that china's proposed contribution to
cutting emissions particularly on coal
goes nowhere near fast enough
or far enough
and if that's the case
will he commit to working with all our
partners in the west and across the
world particularly those vulnerable
countries are already watching the ways
of climate change hit their shores
to take any necessary action to pressure
china to make the right decision
prime minister
uh mr speaker i i want to thank the
right honourable gentleman because if
you look at his own political record
he's done a huge amount of good in this
area is is the truth of the uh of the
battle i thank him for for what he he
has done uh and what is happening in
with china is is is very important but
it's a it's a mixed picture
and it's important not to be uh to be
too
negative at present
yes he's right about a domestic chinese
uh coal fire production and uh we're
hoping for for progress
for progress there uh we're hoping that
when china says uh that they can peak uh
before 2030 in co2 output uh that that
date of before is
correct uh is uh considerably nearer now
than than 20 uh than 2030 so that's
where that's whether the work is is
being done but what is interesting is
that when china made the commitment to
stop the overseas financing for coal
that had an instant impact on many of
china's friends and partners around
the asia pacific region who took the
signal and have also stopped
overseas financing for coal and i think
i it is that climate of uh
the power of the room in the in the cop
that is starting to to make a difference
but
you know
whether it's going to be possible at
this cop to get china to make the
commitments that are that are really
necessary i'm afraid it is just too
early to say
dr liam fox
thank you madam deputy speaker i welcome
all the progress made so far at cop26
and congratulate all those involved
including my right honourable friend but
what would we do if we don't get
agreement on article six and persuade
countries like china to properly price
carbon into their economy our businesses
in the uk are carrying their share of
costs to deal with climate change why
should we allow them to be undercut by
competitors who keep their prices down
by using highly polluting industrial
production techniques truly this is not
something that the free world economies
could tolerate
prime minister my right honourable
friend
knows a great deal about this uh issue
and he's right to draw attention to to
article 60 in the the carbon credit uh
issue and uh that is something on which
our negotiators will be working uh flat
out until the final hour of call
fish brian thank you madam deputy
speaker one of the terrible effects of
climate change is felt in south wells
valley seats where um
extreme weather conditions and heavy
rain have destabilized some of the tips
the disused coal tips
people live in terror of another abba
van and i know the prime minister shares
that fear
and this was
all these uh the majority of the
dangerous tips are in my local authority
area i just wonder whether he'd be
prepared to meet with myself the leader
of the local council and the other
members for ronda cunning taft
specifically to discuss how we can make
sure that all of these tips are safe i
really do ask him for that meeting
prime minister i thank the the right
honourable general he's raised this
issue uh with me several times i will
see what i can do to to oblige him and i
i i i know that uh this is uh uh it's
something that i i do want to try to fix
but it's primarily something that the
welsh uh government should be it's
primarily something that the welsh
government should be addressing
themselves i will i will i will talk to
the welsh government and and come back
to him
i strongly congratulate the prime
minister on throwing his heart and soul
at cop 26 no one could have worked
harder yeah yeah the uk is responsible
for one percent of global carbon
emissions china is responsible for 28
since 2000
two two-thirds of the increase in global
carbon emissions have come from china
is china's commitment to reach peak coal
in 2030 an aspiration or a binding
target
prime minister i think what uh president
xi jinping would say is that uh china
uh keeps its promises
um
we will have to hope that that is
that is true um
i think that the people of the world
will want to hold all of us all
governments to account but he is
completely right to focus on the
particular
pressure that
china faces
from us and from and from the whole
world
caroline lucas
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
i welcome the prime minister's recent
conversion to the climate cause and i
agree with him that the clock is indeed
at one minute to midnight which begs the
question as why his snooze button was on
for so long but he'll know that the
first rule of diplomacy is to walk the
talk so will he now take this
opportunity to put real credibility
behind his stirring words to lead by
example and to commit now finally to
reverse the decision on the cambod oil
field yes or no very simple
prime minister mr speaker
what i can tell the uh right honourable
lady is that we continue to reduce our
dependence on fossil fuels of all kinds
uh we will be going for a complete net
zero in our uh our power production by
2035 moving beyond coal uh by 2024
and i think it was the i read i think it
was the scottish nationalist a national
party minister who said that uh oil was
a still a part of of scotland's future
uh i say nothing about the cambodia what
i will say is that there is a future for
hydrocarbons in in so far as you can
liberate the hydrogen and make clean
energy
stephen hammond
thank you speaker can i congratulate my
right honourable friend on his
leadership of cop and particularly the
achievement of getting 100 countries to
sign up to the methane pledge
but he will know that some of the
biggest submitters have not uh signed up
to that so when will the power of the
room which he described a moment ago
be on those countries to sign up to the
pledge as well
prime minister uh nah mr speaker we're
just going to keep going and you know
this is this is a rolling series of
negotiations we're ringing people up the
whole time uh the the cop is in full
full flood at the moment
claire anderson
thank you madam dr speaker
the prime minister has not yet mentioned
water resilience and yet that is top of
the agenda for many of the countries
that are most affected by the climate
emergency
can he say what his assessment is of the
water is funding for water resilience
project is and commits not to cutting
them but to increasing funding for water
resilience
prime minister mr speaker we support
water resilience projects around the
world as part of the fc uh as part of
the fcdo and i had a good discussion on
uh the issue of uh water of water and
resilience and other aspects of climate
change resilience with uh vulnerable
countries over the last few days
james gray
the prime minister knows very well that
the north of scotland is rather closer
to the arctic circle that is to london
and they delicate at cop26 who doubts
the climate emergency all they have to
do is glance at the retreating ice or
the melting pepper frost or the methane
been being released as a result to be
convinced that this emergency really is
happening
madame speaker the chinese will benefit
particularly from the withdrawal of the
ice as the northern sea route opens up
particularly for barca is carrying coal
and while the prime minister not
therefore agree with me the chinese have
a doubly important moral obligation to
stick by their commitment to reduce the
production of coal in china otherwise we
in the west we will be burning their
coal
prime minister
my right old friend is completely right
to point out the the consequences for
the world of the retreat of the uh of
the ice in the uh towards the north pole
it it will not i'm afraid it will offer
opportunities not just for china but
actually also for ourselves and and
scarpa flow in other parts of the
of of scotland uh will become uh
potentially very important for for sea
traffic of a clean green variety madam
deputy speaker
sammy wilson
unbelievable
prime minister and pursuit of the
dramatic reductions in the minuscule
co2 emissions produced by this country
ordinary people are facing higher petrol
prices higher energy prices restrictions
on what they can drive replacement of
gas boilers higher grain taxes on their
declining incomes
can the prime minister understand their
frustration and disdain that those who
tell them they must burn these burdens
fly into glasgow in their private jets
ferry around the town in their
gas clothing cavalcades and more
fundamentally
those he really believes given the huge
natural forces which have changed the
world's climate continually that somehow
thereby reducing co2 we can turn the
world's thermostat up and down at will
prime minister mr speaker first of all
where this country is moving to uh net
zero for uh or moving to
uh zero emission vehicles he talks about
gas causes uh we're supporting jet zero
aviation mr speaker and when he talks
that when his big objection is to the to
the science and he and he says that uh
he's obviously a complete climate
skeptic mr speaker he should he should
he should he should look uh at the graph
uh
madam deputy speaker uh he should look
at the graph uh he should look at the
graph showing the core of the clear
which david attenborough and deputy
speaker produced on on the first day of
the summit showing the clear correlation
between the huge anthropogenic spike in
co2 and the current rise in temperatures
and the way that temperatures track co2
volumes in the air over the last
thousands of years the the science is
absolutely clear and i think actually
the people of this country know that the
way forward for it would be an economic
disaster an economic disaster not to
address this and what the people of this
country know is that clean green
technology can deliver higher wages and
fantastic jobs for generations to come
and they see a great future in this
so you've met carl
thank you madam deputy speaker um and i
really just want to reinforce the point
the prime minister has just made because
i want him to reassure my constituents
that the goal of achieving net zero is
not a burden to be born but an
opportunity to be grasped to create new
innovative jobs and new sectors in which
we can lead the world yeah
prime minister it's a speaker our green
industrial madam nephew a green
industrial revolution uh alone uh
generates uh the 26 billion pounds that
we're putting in generates 440 000
more more jobs uh jobs in
in battery technology uh jobs in
ev manufacture jobs in uh in in wind
farms uh jobs in maintenance there are
the opportunities are vast for this
country and we are at the cutting edge
yeah yeah yeah
davey
thank you madam deputy speaker um i
welcome the statement today but does the
prime minister uh believe like i do that
it is important to encourage more people
to use rail instead of other carbon
intensive transport methods and if so um
why is he cutting duty on domestic
flights or will he now rethink this
decision
speaker there's a very clear uh climate
reason for putting up uh duty on uh long
haul uh because that accounts for 96 of
the of the emissions uh and in the case
of uh of our own united kingdom with its
far-flung uh islands uh represented uh
by some distinguished members on the on
the benches opposite it it is
it is it is a a useful thing uh to to to
remove barriers remove barriers to
to movement
he'll waken
given the phenomenal success to end on
reverse deforestation i was tempted to
tease my right honourable friend about
build back beavers however will he meet
me to discuss what can be done using
institutions like kew gardens to reverse
the the spread of deserts through better
planting of trees prime minister i i
thank my right honourable offender now
that's a brilliant idea queue has played
an amazing midwife role over the
centuries in in taking uh plants from uh
one part of the world uh uh nurturing
them and then planting them with huge
advantage uh in other parts of the world
and that is certainly something that i'd
be happy to take up with him as
carmichael thank you very much madam
victory speaker can i say to the prime
minister i think he's absolutely right
that this is a moment for turning words
into action and one very important but
quite small action that he and his
government could take now
would be the creation of a ring-fenced
pot for the development of tidal stream
energy in the next round of contract for
difference options this is a decision
that has to be taken by the end of this
month will the prime minister talk to
his colleagues in bees in the treasury
and make sure that it happens
prime minister well um madam deputy
speaker this is a point that i i've now
heard several times from uh benches uh
bench's opposite and i i am myself you
know without having the the perhaps all
the technical expertise i am very
impressed by the title uh proposals that
i have seen i i what i will undertake to
the right honourable gentleman not to
make an absolute commitment on on the
contract for difference or the strike
price for title power but i will
certainly go away and look at it again
like a fabricant
thank you madam deputy speaker
well done prime minister in motivating
people
and for delivering that which others
were saying couldn't be delivered uh at
cop 26 so far just a couple of days in
actually to a two weeks program but can
i invite my right honourable friend
to visit rolls royce
who are working on developing a 100
sustainable fuel jet engine for aviation
and put his considerable weight and i
don't mean that in a personal manner i
mean as prime minister he's considerable
weight behind the gigafactory proposal
for coventry in the west midlands
combined authority
prime minister i i thank my my own
honorable friend i can tell you i i in
fact it was only a couple of weeks ago
uh that uh the entire cabinet was in uh
bristol looking at with with rolls royce
looking at what they're doing uh with
gkn and other companies to to to to go
for sustainable aviation uh madam madam
deputy speaker and uh i i i also can
tell him that we are looking actively at
what we can do to support a a
gigafactory in the in the in the
coventry area but there are obviously
commercial discussions underway
liam burn
thank you madam speaker and as chair of
the g7 and of course the prime minister
will know that the world community is 20
billion dollars short of what's needed
for the vaccination program
and we have missed the hundred billion
dollars promised for climate finance now
the imf has given the world a shot in
the arm 650 billion dollars of special
drawing rights which the prime minister
helped push for we have been given 20
billion pounds more than the entire
community of low-income countries put
together but why are we being so slow
and so sluggish in recycling that money
back to the imf so it could be put to
good use we're behind france we're
behind america we're a laggard when we
should be leading
families we're doing this madam deputy
speaker is putting uh hard cash into
supporting uh countries around the world
uh he makes a a good point about the
sdrs uh we're looking at that as well
but we're prioritizing uh cash up front
well jenkinson
thank you madam deputy speaker my
rational friend knows that i'm a fervent
supporter of his efforts to for the uk
to lead the world in decarbonisation
and i know that he would not wish to
impoverish anyone here or abroad on the
way
no country has yet leapfrogged our path
to prosperity from wood coal gas to
nuclear
and my concern is that in asking
development countries to consign coal
power to history we risk sustaining the
poverty
if we don't provide an alternative do
you agree with his historic
climate finance agreements
and our existing development aid we have
a huge opportunity to export uk smr
around the world to hasten their path to
prosperity instead
thank my honourable friend for what i
think is an exceedingly thoughtful
question and uh he is absolutely right
in the logic of what he says uh we must
help uh the developing world to to
leapfrog uh i think that uh all sorts of
technologies uh are very attractive
including uh the one that he suggests
and the opportunity there is to is to is
to generate
fantastic british jobs as well
dietrich
thank you madam deputy speaker um open
democracy uh reported recently his
former colleague in the eu vote leave
campaign nigel farage as saying that a
referendum on green taxes could well be
his latest campaign
we're hearing increasingly loud
objections from the so-called net zero
scrutiny group from amongst his own rank
of mps and the institute of economic
affairs said recently it would continue
to challenge the ropey economics of net
zero what will the pm do to challenge
those siren voices from amongst his own
supporters prime minister i think i i
study the uh
people's feelings about this and what's
so changed in this court madam deputy
speaker from paris which i attended and
or from copenhagen which i was also uh
at
this time the it's the it's the public
uh who you know i have great respect for
colleagues around the house who say this
is all going too far too fast and uh
people can't afford it uh actually i
don't think we can afford not to do it i
also think that it is economically a
massive opportunity for this country and
i think that's where people increasingly
are and i think that you know calls for
a referendum on this will not uh fall on
uh we'll fall on stony ground yeah yeah
richard graham
madame speaker i spent the last couple
of days at cop 26 with southeast asian
nations representatives and the
situation is exactly as the prime
minister has described real progress on
cash coal and trees particularly
momentum signing up to the forestry
declaration
my right on friend will know that the uk
pavilion is symbolically right opposite
next year's g20 chair indonesia does he
agree with me that using the clean green
finance initiative is a real opportunity
for us to do more to help them
transition from coal-fired energy to
renewable energy often in collaboration
with uk partners on wind and solar and
marine energy
yes i mean i thank my honourable friend
by the way for everything that he's done
with asean partners uh madam deputy
speaker he's been absolutely leading the
uh leading the charge for us in that
region and particularly with uh with
indonesia and they are
great partners of ours and what what
what is coming up out of uh of cop is
this idea that
the countries who are finding it tough
as as my honourable friend said to move
beyond coal uh what they need is uh a
coalition of countries to come to help
them uh with a with a platformer a
portfolio of programs that they need to
get done uh whether it's uh hydro power
or or carbon capturings or storage
whatever it is
that we can help to
to finance to de-risk in order to
leverage in the trillions of the private
sector as we did with wind power in our
country madam deputy speaker and people
as people are seeing this model as the
way in which we can do it not with uh
grants and handouts endlessly from uh
from governments around the world from
the richer countries but from
stimulating the private sector to come
in and uh and deliver a quantum leap in
the infrastructure concern
jack trovey
um
madame de community speaker gk and
melrose have announced their intention
to perceive it the closure of the
erdington plant employing 519 loyal
long-serving workers in an area of the
fifth highest
area of deprivation
in britain
exporting
production to poland still burning coal
on a grand scale for years to come
does the prime minister therefore
understand the dismay of the workers
concerned and does he agree
that with the industry the automotive
industry in transition to an electric
future
we need a supply chain here in britain
employing workers here in britain
manufacturing here in britain as part of
a green industrial revolution here in
britain
prime minister yes uh uh madam deputy
speaker i passionately agree with that
and that's why
i think it's absolutely right that
we should support uh fantastic gk does
an amazing job uh across the country but
particularly in uh in
delivering some of the most difficult
solutions such as sustainable aviation
what we need to do is ensure that we
have the
the ecosystem of uh gigafactories of uh
ev manufacturing capabilities
and all supply chains here in britain
but with an energy cost uh that those
businesses uh that allows them to be
competitive that applies to steel it
applies to automotive it applies to
everything i'm afraid at the moment the
differential between our domestic uh
users electricity costs and industrial
energy cost is too high and we've got to
fix it
jason mccartney thank you madam deputy
speaker as chair of the all party
parliamentary group for woods and trees
can i thank the prime minister and the
negotiating teams for their fantastic
work in tackling deforestation
can i also welcome the government's
continued commitment to the northern
forest madame deputy speaker planting 50
million trees across the north hopefully
many of them in south yorkshire as well
and finally will the prime minister join
me in appealing to community groups and
schools to get involved with the queen's
green canopy project as we all plant a
tree for the jubilee
prime minister i i thank my my
honourable friend he's completely right
the
amount of deputy speaker the planting a
a tree for the jubilee is a wonderful
thing to do we should all be doing it we
want to plant 36 000 hectares of trees
every year as part of our contribution
and one of the many ways in which we're
contributing uh to fight climate change
but also to beautify our landscape yeah
kerry mccarthy thank you madam deputy
speaker as chair of the appg on small
island developing states i welcome the
fact that the prime minister
acknowledged the imminent threat to them
in his statement there's two things that
would really help them one is access to
the finance that hopefully is now on the
table because as countries with very
limited resources it's very difficult
they tell me to actually get their hands
on the money and to do the bids the
other thing is to develop blue finance
we know that the city of london leads on
green finance blue finance for the blue
economy and marine conservation would
really really help them and i think we
could take a lead on that
prime minister i think she's completely
right about uh the the imperative of
helping the small island states i must
say that at cop and in the last few
months they've been incredibly valuable
in getting the world to focus or they're
you know they're in pain with the
maldives uh the seychelles uh bangladesh
the catastrophic flight flooding that
they uh they face in bangladesh uh
mauritius they they face barbados was
brilliant uh uh the other day you know
they are helping to focus minds on the
issue and to attract massive sums of
investment
about palsy thank you madam deputy
speaker the uk can be very proud of the
commitments we've already made but some
of our actions are in danger of making
our manufacturing and our heavy industry
in particular and competitive so could i
ask the prime minister once again is
there any significance in the absence
from cop 26 by leaders of our industrial
competitors such as china and russia is
he confident that they can persuaded to
do more after the conference to provide
a more level playing field
prime minister i thank my honorable
friend for the the point that he makes
but and i understand why he should be uh
anxious but i i talked to both uh
president xi and president putin and it
was clear you know that they they said
by the deputy speaker that the pandemic
precluded them from coming and and and i
understand the situation that they're in
they have very senior negotiators there
in in glasgow as we speak uh
uh shia is a
very senior uh uh operative in the uh in
the chinese system and uh we've got to
hope for for results in the end this is
the change is going to be driven not
just by the the feelings of people in
the in the western democracies but also
by the political pressure that is gonna
that is all that is already and the
pressure from business that is already
being felt uh within china and russia as
well exactly david clinton
thank you very much madame deputy
speaker i was pleased to see in the
prime minister's statement and reference
to action on trees you'll be aware that
in scotland we produce 80 percent of
woodland planting all across these
islands
not least by small groups like mount
vernon community hall which is a real
effort on biodiversity but what more can
the prime minister do elsewhere in the
uk to try and get action on pre-planting
and follow the lead of scotland and the
deep mount vernon
hi minister uh i thank him i i
congratulate
uh scottish tree planting
groups on the the initiatives that
they've taken that he's absolutely right
the huge numbers of trees are planted in
scotland we want to see uh the rest of
the uk catch up and uh and do better i'm
afraid the rates did decline a bit
during the the pandemic uh we've got to
accelerate and i think uh what my
honourable friend said just now about
plantar tree for the jubilee is
absolutely right
david morris
i'm deputy speaker ma'am deputy speaker
later on we're talking about nuclear in
this chamber so that's showing that the
government is now looking forward to the
future as we've two nuclear power
stations in heating but what i would
also like to draw to the prime
minister's attention is that we're doing
wondrous works with prepare for the eden
project in morecambe and i know i
invited him last week in pmq's and i'm
still pushing it boris come and see us
in morgan
okay i was unrelenting uh uh uh
invitation of course uh
deputy speaker i'll do my utmost to
oblige my honourable friend who's a
great campaigner
for clean power and and uh as he knows
we're taking forward uh plans for smrs
as well
elaine greenwood thank you madam deputy
speaker transport makes up the largest
share of uk carbon emissions but rail
travel is clean and green so i ask again
why on earth is the prime minister
choosing to make it cheaper to take
domestic flights while failing to set
out a proper plan for rail
electrification
failing to confirm a high-speed rail
line to the east midlands and the north
and putting up rail fares
prime minister
madam deputy speaker what we're doing is
investing massively in uh in in rail the
way i described in pmq's earlier on uh
we're not trusted with hs2 but north
northern powerhouse rail the the irp
and uh and uh
and she she objects to
uh to domestic air travel uh but the the
vision that she should support uh is the
idea of moving away uh from using uh
tons of kerosene to uh hurl planes into
the air you can you can do it you can do
it with uh with other approaches and
that's that's what we should be
following yeah
thomas thank you madam deputy speaker i
welcome the prime minister's leadership
particularly around the world in getting
the biggest the world's biggest
polluters to reduce their carbon
footprint
my constituents are keen to move forward
and to transition to a de-carbon
lifestyle and i believe that information
with the prime minister agreed me that
information to them is key to this now
there are many times where we
consumers all of us will purchase things
from china that may well be able
available here in the uk but we don't
understand the carbon footprint the
inbox carbon footprint in that item
would the prime minister agree the
information about how
carbon is uh held within items that we
purchased is important for consumers yes
prime minister um
schools in cornwall i've i've been
talking that they they have a fantastic
understanding of what cornwall is doing
uh to cut carbon at the amazing projects
in in cornwall and we're also uh making
sure that uh
in education in classes kids do
understand the in the in-built carbon
cost of the goods that they buy
stephen ferry thank you deputy speaker
at present the uk doesn't yet have
measures in place to reach carbon
neutral by the year at 2050 and indeed
last week the chancellor couldn't even
mention climate change once in an
hour-long speech on the budget
so surely the uk should be offering
leadership in this area by putting in
place a comprehensive green new deal
that combines economic and social policy
alongside measures to combat climate
change
prime minister
well
madame dempsey i don't know what planet
the right the honourable general has
been on uh uh he is totally wrong he is
totally wrong this this government has
helped to cut
the uk's emissions of co2 by almost half
on 1990 levels it's an astonishing thing
to have done we have the most ambitious
uh nationally determined contribution of
any uh country in the eu
78
uh by 2035 or 1990 levels and we're
gonna we're doing it through all the the
measures that he that he knows had has
he not heard about what we're going to
do on uh zero emission vehicles or what
we're doing on our power emissions and
amanda just i think i think he needs to
look at what is happening yes of course
of course there is of course there is
more to do but as for as for green bonds
uh we issued uh one the other day and
got 10 billion pounds out of it so
you just keep up man
i would
thank you madam deputy speaker as well
as cars the world will need a clean
smart urban transport if we're to meet
the
the climate uh challenge
companies like westfield pods in dudley
south are developing products that can
succeed they can thrive that can help us
decarbonize but too often the regulatory
framework lags behind the innovation
will the prime minister work with
ministers and our international partners
to develop international tight type
approval standards
so that uh so so that these products can
succeed that we can decarbonize uh
transport on an urban level as well as
personal cars minister i agree 100
uh with what my honorable friend has
said and uh and i look forward to seeing
the westfield pods and their their means
of conveying human beings around i can't
quite imagine what they are but uh but
what we want amanda's using this country
is regulators for growth yeah yeah we
want an approach that and for green
growth and we need a much more uh
proactive uh approach that engages uh
with uh brilliant brilliant ideas like
that
kat smith
thank you madam deputy speaker moving to
rail travel and away from more cabin
intensive forms of transport it's going
to be essential if we're to meet our
ambitions to tackling the climate
emergency
two years ago the prime minister visited
poulton
and announced that he was his commitment
to reopen the railway line to fleetwood
so can he tell my fleetwood constituents
what progress he's making with that and
when they can expect to catch the
train from fleetwood into the entire
national rail network
prime minister uh i i i think uh what
we're doing is uh a general program of
beaching reversals around the country
i'll get back to as soon as i can about
uh what is is happening in in bolton uh
but this is the biggest investment in uh
rail for uh for a century or more
henry smith
thank you madam deputy speaker an
estimated 15 percent of global carbon
emissions comes from
livestock production around the world
more than all transportation
put
together on the
former what discussions have been had at
cop26
with our international partners on
reducing that and on the latter also
what discussions have there been in
terms of the rest of the world taking
the lead
from the united kingdom in terms of
sustainable aviation technology
prime minister
thank you so first of all on uh
livestock emissions uh my older friend
is absolutely right that methane is is a
very powerful greenhouse gas it does
degrade quite fast uh methane so uh it
it's not it's not as as
as as bad as as co2 in some ways but we
need we do need to cut methane emissions
we've committed to doing it by by 30
percent uh agriculture is a particularly
difficult uh problem uh but there are
ways of of doing it and uh without uh
moving away from uh from livestock
farming there are things you can do with
breeding and other and other techniques
to reduce methane emissions and we're
certainly we're certainly looking at
that
thank you um speaker the the the premise
is right to tell the the house and
indeed the world how exciting these
promises are on the reforestation on the
methane reduction but he will also
recall that 12 years ago when the rich
countries committed to 100 billion pound
dollars every year transfer to the poor
there was no mechanism for measuring
that progress and the world failed
can he tell us what the legacy will be
particularly around the forest
deforestation so there is a proper
mechanism that holds to account uh
president bolsonaro the indonesians
wherever it may be
prime minister
yes
he makes a very incredibly important
point and that there are two ways of of
holding uh the the governments to
account whether it's
uh china brazil uh russia or any anyone
or ourselves and the first is that it's
not only the governments that have
signed up but also uh corporations the
big commodities corporations the big uh
cargill or whoever uh they have agreed
no longer to uh use products that are
the sources are as a result of
deforestation and consumers
consumers will hold them to account as
well as governments for what they do
secondly uh the financial institutions
uh worth trillions of barclays aviva
many many
financial institutions around the world
have agreed that they will not finance
uh projects that uh depend upon
deforestation and again their investors
their shell hurdles uh everybody
involved in those that will hold them to
account for what they do and if they
cheat and if they invest in
deforestation they will suffer because
as i said earlier on in uh to the house
uh what is what is changing now is the
power of the consumer the power of the
voters the the power of of the world
that wants their governments to do the
right thing now
thank you madam deputy speaker would the
prime minister join with me in
congratulating the staff and pupils at
asgard dennis brown in clangothlon whom
i visited recently
dennis brown on the excellent work that
they're doing in i'm studying climate
change and also making sure working
closely with the dembertia county
council to make sure that their school
operates on a carbon neutral basis
prime minister yeah
well it could i give you great pleasure
to to congratulate the skull dennis
brown which i i know
uh from my own um abortive attempt to
win the seat that he's now uh that he
that he now represents so so well and i
i thank them uh for what they're doing
and i think they're quite right to set
the example that they're setting all new
schools uh in our country are carbon
neutral here help house
thank you madame deputy speaker i want
to thank him for the update on the g20
summit and um cop 26 and also for
listening very carefully from the
suggestions um from these benches and
i'm sure he too will be very
disappointed that the g20 could not
agree on an end date for domestic fossil
fuel use so will he be brave
show leadership and set an end date
for the extraction and domestic use of
all fossil fuels in the uk
we will have no fossil fuels in our
power generation system at all uh from
2035 uh madam deputy speaker
great davis
and dr speaker
six percent of global gdp is spent on
fossil fuel subsidies which is
destroying our planet and china spends
more on fossil fuel subsidies than the
united states russia and europe the eu
combined so will he take leadership on
reducing fossil fuel
subsidies but in particular uh support
carbon border attacks has been promoted
by the eu so we don't have a situation
where uk steel for instance made in
wales is being displaced by chinese
stale made from coal just twice the
carbon footprint so we can protect local
jobs and save the planet through greener
trade
prime minister uh
madam deputy speaker i think that uh our
steel companies have done a great job of
trying to reduce their uh their carbon
footprint it's extremely hard if you're
if you're a steel corporation they're
one of the biggest emitters that we have
we've got a uh we've got to move towards
uh zero uh carbon uh steel making whilst
keeping a steel making industry in this
country i think the measures that he
describes the carbon border adjustment
levy all those sorts of things are
certainly certainly worth considering
robert ferrier
thank you madam deputy speaker the un
secretary general has said it will be
very difficult to secure the commitment
needed for the 1.5 degree goal and in
relation to new fossil fuel explorations
i quote we don't need more oil and gas
while the prime minister say what
engagement his government is having with
the oil and gas industries to support
them in their efforts to decarbonize
sustainably
promise we talk thank you uh madame
deputy we talked the whole time to the
oil and gas industry which has a great
history of proud industry in this
country i believe that the future for
the oil and gas industry for
hydrocarbons is moving uh beyond the the
old uh combustion approach and towards
extraction of clean power that's that's
the way we should be going
just in matters
thank you madam deputy speaker it does
feel like we're in
last chance to learn if we are going to
make an impact on women limiting the
effect of climate change so does the
prime minister share my disappointment
that china and india have failed to
match
many other countries commitments to
reach net zero by 2050 and
only putting their targets 10 and 20
years later on and does he agree with me
as well if cop 26 the remainder of it is
going to be a success we need to get
some movement from them on that as well
prime minister i thank him we'll
continue to push on those on those net
zero dates and i i i frankly agree with
the the characterization that he makes
of of those targets but i think you need
to look also at what uh both those
countries are saying about what they'll
do pre-2030
and as uh as the right on the lady
opposite said uh you know that's that's
the key thing that i think we really
need to to focus on the indians have now
made a big commitment on decarbolizing
their power system uh by 2013 and you've
heard what we've already said in this
house about the chinese commitment
uh to peak uh output for co2 in 2030 or
before the question is how long before
so you know both those countries
actually have made substantial progress
it's obviously not yet enough
edwards
speaker
in this statement the prime minister
said we have the technology to do what
is necessary all that remains in
question is our resolve
with this in mind why doesn't the
british government extend the favorable
financing model being proposed for
nuclear energy generation to other
technologies such as the proposed
swansea tidal lagoon
prime minister uh i thank him very much
and
uh as as he knows i i
was very attracted to the swansea tidal
lagoon model uh uh
it is extremely expensive for the energy
it it produces it's not uh that and if
if the if
and i i see uh members opposite shaking
their heads if they can if they can
produce uh
plans that show a more economical way of
doing it then i'd be only too happy to
study them
fine question sam terry
thank you madam deputy speaker earlier
today cop 26 young people from the group
nude green deal rising trying to ask the
chancellor directly about why he
continues to subsidise fossil fuels in
the fossil fuel industry so deeply
instead of engaging with those young
people the young people that could be
the first generation to die of climate
change not of old age he promptly banned
them from attending his talk
i wonder that i'm deputy speaker whether
the prime minister and the chancellor
could instead engage with that
generation engage with those young
people and move on from greenwash
towards a green new deal to raise
britain up and meet our climate
obligations
prime minister madam deputy speaking
precisely for the sake of that uh
generation
with whom by the way every member of
this government i'm sure members around
the house engaged the whole time on this
issue uh it's precisely for their sakes
that we are we're doing this and i think
that they are actually starting to think
that we can fix this i'm starting to
think that we can fix this i was i was
pretty gloomy a while back but i do
think that we have the technology we
certainly have the finance i think we
have the we have a growing package of
solutions that we can bring to bear and
i think it will be a massive benefit to
young children growing up in this
country and i hope uh because one of the
things i worry about is young young
people in this country are mentally very
badly affected by the prospect of of
serious climate change i think it's
something that prays on their minds
and we need to lift that burden from
them and show them that there is a there
is a more hopeful alternative and i
really think that that is starting to
appear yeah yeah
i thank the prime minister for his
statement and we now come to the uh ten
minute rule motion robert
[Music]
yeah yeah um thank you madam deputy
speaker i i beg to move that leave be
given to bring in a bill to make
provision for educational settings
including early years schools colleges
and universities to be classed as
essential infrastructure and remain open
to all students during public health and
other national emergencies and for
connected purposes
between the start of the pandemic and
july 2021 british children were out of
their classrooms almost half of the
available school days as a result of
nationwide shutdowns and isolations
the majority of the country's
universities switched to remote learning
with many students still not returned to
full face-to-face teaching
these closures wielded a hammer glow to
our children and young people's
education and well-being
the mechanisms this bill will put in
place will safeguard the education the
mental health and the chances of those
already hardest here and for future
generations to come
before i begin let me take a moment to
give special thanks to the teachers and
support staff who did all they can to
keep children learning over the past 18
months
i specially welcome the support of
children's commissioners past and
present for this bill two former
children's ministers and significantly
the parents group us for them
who've campaigned day and night to keep
schools fully open and our children
learning in the classrooms as they
should be
it's beyond doubt that for those who
engage in online learning less material
was covered that would have been in the
classroom
moreover many children could not
participate in online learning at all
school closures and the move to online
learning increased the existing
inequalities between those from
disadvantaged backgrounds and their
better off peers
mr speaker the facts speak for
themselves and testify to what parents
know instinctively a tablet is no
substitute for in-person schooling and
their inspiration and guidance that
teachers and support staff provide a
laptop cannot replace the enriching
nurturing and skills building
environment that the school community
gives to our children